we're going to be taking a deep look at
2024 today we're going to look at all
sorts of new approval polls for both the
democratic and republican side but
before we do that i have to start with a
story that many of you i know will say
david this this can't be this has to be
a low even fox news even the right wing
wouldn't do this would they and yes they
did
fox news hosts are now worried
that the rapidly declining gas prices
that we're seeing
might be bad
for local mom and pop gas stations i
know guys i know after
months and months and months of saying
the high gas prices
are the uh end of the of the country
they are joe biden's fault it is
inflation it's ruining everything the
high gas prices are so terrible
now that gas prices have been declining
for about a month and of course they
don't want to give joe biden any credit
for it which by the way i don't think he
deserves but they were blaming biden on
the way up now they're silent
now they're saying you know
these lower gas prices
they might be bad for gas stations
listen to this it is beyond parody let's
uh want him to run again
and the rest probably don't
that is stunning by the way on gas
prices i found it curious i was at a
lacrosse tournament up in wilmington
delaware over the weekend in delaware
and northern maryland regular gas is
about anywhere from 455 to 480 a gallon
so the price is beginning to creep back
down it is it is and the point was made
over the weekend i believe it's the wall
street journal that gas prices are
actually coming back down historically
faster with the price of oil than usual
and it just goes to show you what an
incredible
risk uh reward calculation has to happen
on the part of those small independently
owned most of them mom and pop gas
stations it's a struggle for all of them
yeah still a long way from 355 a gallon
but you know maybe some movement in that
direction hey they can't find peace and
privacy yeah no guys listen i mean we
really have to now think about these mom
and pop gas stations all of a sudden
prices are coming down this could really
be a bad thing for them so we'll ask the
question of whether that's even true
just as a reminder gas prices indeed
coming down they peaked right around
really about a month ago right right in
mid-june and have been uh in a
relatively steep decline i mean it is
true that normally as i've as i've told
you before
there's this phenomenon where you see
oil prices go up and then gas prices go
up in parallel but then when oil comes
back down the gas prices only trickle
down at a lower rate and we've seen this
with airfare we've seen this in a lot of
different
areas that are dependent on the oil
price but we're actually seeing a
relatively
rapid decline of gas prices now down to
about 464 from a high of about 5.03 so
it is true that gas prices are coming
down now the question is is it bad for
the mom and pops is it bad for gas
stations when gas prices are lower which
would imply that it's good for gas
stations when prices are higher now
this is not actually even true and so
with all of these uh um
discussions
first you know we get the claim from fox
first we want to verify the fact our gas
price is even coming down and yes they
are coming down and i've reported that
to you the next question is do the local
gas stations suffer when prices come
down it doesn't really work that way
when when oil prices go up
what you actually sometimes see
is gas stations which make very little
off of gas
try to out-compete competitors
by
really eating some of the price increase
so you will see
the gas stations know okay oil prices
are up the cost we are now paying for
gas is up so we have to raise our retail
price
i'm going to try to raise the price less
than my competitor down the street
because i make more money from the
slushies and the peanut m ms and the 10
sunglasses or whatever else so in fact
sometimes higher gas prices higher gas
prices are quite good um for the oil
companies but they are not necessarily
so good for the local gas stations and
uh during higher prices after expenses
gas stations will often make only five
cents a gallon sometimes even less
and um uh that compares to what is often
like a 15 to 20 cent per gallon profit
for gas stations during more stable gas
prices so
multiple aspects of this the big one is
the hypocrisy they've been pulling their
hair out with the sky is falling type
stuff for a year now about high gas
prices which they say are joe biden's
fault
we get a month of declines in gas prices
now they say oh no
lower gas prices aren't so good for the
mom and pop gas stations what about for
all of the commuters that you've been
talking about for a year
that's the main story the maybe just as
interesting one is that high gas prices
are not particularly good for the mom
and pop gas stations for the reasons
that i just said so it's
it's unbelievable that fox i mean it's
they should be embarrassed that now
they're saying gas prices might be going
down too quickly they might get too low
it's an embarrassment but of course
their followers absolutely love it they
never get any contradictory information
from other networks obviously they
should be saying wait this is a
contradictory message from fox they've
been telling me the higher gas prices
are bad all this time now they're saying
the lower gas prices could be bad what
is bad what is good they're not they're
not going to go through that process and
they will accept what is spoon fed to
them but absurd
hypocrisy from fox news okay
let's now get into 2024. joe biden's
approval has absolutely collapsed now i
was right there
telling you
when his approval was low but still
historically higher than many presidents
at this point in time i was telling you
that i was saying yeah it's low-ish but
he's still doing better than abcde
presidents at this point in their first
term
you have to go back to the 1940s now to
find a first-term president
with a lower approval rating at this
point right july of the second year of
his presidency
than joe biden and we're going to get to
those numbers but this is coming at a
time where also
most democrats are saying they don't
want joe biden to run in 2024 now i
don't believe he is going to run in 2024
uh but we're going to get to that in a
moment most democrats don't want biden
in 24 new polls shows
uh president biden is facing an alarming
level of doubt from inside his own party
64 percent of democratic voters say they
would prefer a new standard bearer in
2024. this is from a new york times
siena college poll voters nationwide
have soured on his leadership giving a
meager 33 job approval rating we'll look
at an average of approval rating in a
moment it's a little bit higher than
that in this particular poll it's at 33
widespread concerns about the economy
and inflation have helped turn the
national mood decidedly dark both on
biden and their trajectory of the nation
more than three-quarters of registered
voters see the u.s moving in the wrong
direction a pervasive sense of pessimism
that spans every corner of the country
every age range every racial group
cities suburbs and rural areas and both
political parties only 13 percent of
american voters say the nation is on the
right track
now in terms of approval
uh joe biden's approval on average is
down to
38.6
this is uh as you can see here the
lowest of his presidency uh he kicked
off his presidency in the mid 50s and
remained there for several months then
started seeing a decline last summer as
the kovid surge happened negative press
about getting out of afghanistan etc
a brief bump towards the end of the year
and then a continued decline this is
really not good and when you look at
historical numbers which 538 allows you
to do you now see that joe biden's
approval rating has dipped below where
donald trump's was at this point in time
we're roughly at day 550
where are we roughly five
about 545 of the presidency uh donald
trump had a higher approval rating at
this point barack obama had a higher
approval rating at this point george w
bush had a higher approval rating so did
clinton george h.w bush was doing far
better than than biden is now reagan was
doing better jimmy carter was doing
better although not by much gerald ford
was doing better nixon was doing better
lbj was doing better jfk and eisenhower
you have to go all the way back
to harry truman
in 1946
to find a president that around day 545
was
had a lower approval than joe biden
that's really really bad
i believe it is time for joe biden to
soon say
i will not be running for reelection in
2024 make it public make it clear allow
for anyone on the democratic side uh to
have time to consider
whether they want to run for president
in 2024 decide whether they want to
mount a campaign and to have a clean
open primary for 2024 and i say this for
a few reasons number one i just don't
think joe biden wants to run for
reelection that that's the most
important thing it's not about pushing
biden out it's i don't see any
indication that he wants to run he'll be
82
at the time the language it continues to
be that he intends to run after kamala
harris definitively said he was running
the next day she had to walk it back
because it's very apparent to all of us
that it's not clear that he actually
plans to run that's the primary reason
he doesn't seem to want to run
and it's becoming
politically disadvantageous to democrats
for everybody to kind of have to pretend
like he is going to run i just don't
think he's running secondly his approval
rating is collapsing and whether it's
donald trump or ron desantis or whoever
on the on the republican side
there is going to be a major uphill
battle
um
for the 2024 election and it would seem
prudent and better to
not rush anyone else into having to
decide am i getting in or am i getting
out make it clear i'm not going to be
running for re-election now i'm not
actually saying that biden should
announce this before the midterms it
probably makes sense to wait for the
midterms but it should be done
relatively soon again biden least
popular president at this point in his
first term dating back to harry truman
in the 1940s
third
even most democrats don't want joe biden
to run so looking at the pulse of the
party also matters now i am right there
with you in saying that even most of the
those democrats who would rather someone
other than biden
would almost certainly vote for biden if
biden is the nominee but it's not
particularly reassuring when it comes to
the possibility that the right will be
really motivated in 2024
okay sure most democrats even if they
would rather someone else would still
vote for biden
but even if it depresses turnout by a
couple of points i don't know that it's
the advantage of the democratic party
now there are many good options on the
democratic side but the question becomes
does kamala harris run and if so
do
biden and the dnc attempt to sort of
anoint her the de facto nominee
she's not popular either and she may
lose a contested primary but whatever is
going to happen there should be time so
that democrats don't get caught
flat-footed now let me say one other
thing
because i already know some of the
messages that i'm going to get there's a
lot of kind of finger wagging going on
at people who aren't feeling inspired or
confident in biden 2024
the finger wagging should probably stop
i'm not saying i wouldn't vote for biden
over trump or desantis in 2024 i would
i'm not even saying joe biden hasn't
done some good things he's done many
good things and i've enumerated them
many times i'm saying it would be better
if biden said what most democrats are
thinking and said i'm not running for
reelection we did a great thing here by
taking the country back from trump we
did a b c d e
and i am clearing the way for a spirited
primary where we are going to get i am
sure a great nominee
to go up against what is going to be
a brutally desperate attempt by
republicans to take back the white house
by any means necessary and we know what
some of those means are that's what i
think would be the best
now if you disagree with me or you agree
with me whatever i want to hear from you
let me know what you think find me on
twitter at d pacman and we will
certainly follow up on this
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
the david pakman show is a community
viewer and listener supported program i
would love for you to sign up at
joinpackman.com
you can use the coupon code big
voting22 to get a discount we do a bonus
show every single day for our members we
also provide a commercial free audio and
video stream of the show roughly five or
six hours earlier than we published the
show to everybody and you also get a
priority a phone line when we do our our
viewer town halls the next of which is
coming up uh soon i have to get the
details on that that'll be announced
very soon sign up at joinpacman.com all
right we're going to look at an
incredible contrast that is taking place
now within the republican party in the
last segment we looked at what's going
on in the democratic party joe biden
approval
voter sentiment about who should run in
2024. let's now look at the republican
party we have on the one hand a stunning
new poll which we will look at which
shows that half of republicans are ready
to abandon trump they want someone else
they're ready to go
and on the other hand donald trump is
still the most popular republican
and every indication is that if there is
a contested republican primary involving
donald trump it's going to be absolutely
and utterly insane so let's start with
the first piece first half of republican
voters are ready to abandon donald trump
far from consolidating his support
writes the new york times the former
president appears weakened in his party
especially with younger and
college-educated republicans governor
ron desantis of florida is the most
popular alternative and that's something
you know if you've been watching the
show because we've been talking about it
as donald trump weighs whether to open
an unusually early white house campaign
that very same new york times sienna
poll which we cited earlier in terms of
joe biden
and democratic voters
shows that trump's post-presidential
quest to consolidate support within the
gop has left him weakened
nearly half of the party's primary
voters seek someone different for
president in 2024 and a significant
number are vowing to abandon trump if he
wins the nomination
trump appears to have deepened fault
lines among republicans during his
year-long revenge tour a clear majority
of primary voters under 35
64
as well as 65 percent of those with at
least a college degree a leading
indicator of preferences in the donor
class told pollsters they would vote
against trump in a presidential primary
reasons include trump's conduct on
january 6th
um
overall trump maintains his primacy in
the party in a hypothetical matchup
against five other republican
presidential rivals 49 of primary voters
say they would support him for a third
nomination so we're gonna d we're gonna
get more into that in a moment but here
are uh some of these interesting numbers
so if a republican 2024 primary were
held today who would you vote for 49 say
donald trump 51 say someone else but as
you can see
no individual alternative
gets more than 25
and that to a great degree
tells us a lot about the potential
dynamics of a very fractured 2024
republican primary and we are going to
get to that now some interesting um
demographic numbers
um trump does much better significantly
better notably better with men rather
than women 52 versus 45
and trump does significantly better with
those who have no college degree in fact
among those with a college degree trump
loses to desantis 32-28 but among those
with no college degree trump more than
doubles ron desantis 58-21 though those
are
extraordinarily
notable and interesting numbers now one
other aspect to this
is that desantis has not run for
president before um and so when you look
at you know cruz is polling roughly
seven percent in in this particular poll
mike pence is polling between
five and ten depending on which
demographic group these are known
entities desantis is not as known and in
fact a quarter of republicans said they
don't even have an opinion of desantis
yet because they don't know enough about
him those who know who desantis is
really like him unfortunately a quarter
don't but that's actually a really good
thing for ron desantis because it
suggests at least that theoretically
that as more republicans come to know
desantis
he may be influential uh in getting
people over to his side and later in
today's show we have a voicemail that
asks sort of an important question about
desantis versus trump uh should desantis
and trump face off in a primary
the poll suggested that support from fox
news could prove crucial and this could
be you know i i think it is fair to say
that at this point fox news has been
weakened from uh its uh prior strength
and it has in part been weakened because
of competitors like newsmax and others
it's in part been weakened because
donald trump has been uh significantly
antagonistic to fox news over the last
year and a half
but uh trump holds a 62 to 26 advantage
over desantis among fox news viewers
but among floridians it's 16 points
closer if they use a different primary
source of news if you don't watch fox
you're much less likely to support trump
over the desantis and that would be uh a
really a really critical thing so
half of republicans again with all of
these things you can look at it glass
half full or glass half empty depending
on who you are
one perspective would be
half of republicans
want someone other than trump that's not
particularly good for a former president
on the other hand
trump doubles every other potential
competitor right now and would easily
win a primary if it were to be held
today
uh and you can
decide for yourself which of those two
perspectives is more relevant or more
valid and um that is the new york times
poll let's now go and talk about what
the primary dynamics could be
despite the fact
that more than half of republicans are
ready to say bye-bye to donald trump
he's still the most popular republican
and the dynamics of a crowded primary in
2024
would almost certainly benefit him
in the same way that he benefited from a
crowded field in 2016 but to a
significantly greater degree and we're
going to explain why a crowded gop field
could help trump in 24
writes jill colvin from the associated
press
as donald trump considers another white
house run polls show he's the most
popular figure in the republican party
but it wasn't always that way competing
at one point against a dozen rivals in
2016 trump won only about a third of the
vote in key early states he even lost in
iowa but he prevailed because those in
the party who opposed his brand of
divisive politics
never coalesced along a single rival and
the same thing could repeat itself as
trump considers a new bid for the
presidency as soon as this summer
with a growing list of candidates
gearing up to run even a trump
diminished by two impeachments and
mounting legal vulnerabilities could
hold a commanding position in a
fractured multi-candidate primary and
the article goes on to say interestingly
that anxiety is mounting as there's a
growing list of rivals potential rivals
taking increasingly brazen steps this
includes mike pence mike pompeo ted cruz
tom cotton rick scott tim scott
liz chaney and larry hogan are raising
profiles and of course ron desantis
increasingly seen as trump's heir
apparent so the scenario with the
crowded field is almost certainly good
for trump if the republican party
and i'm not giving them advice it's an
observation if the republican party said
we want to put party over person
and defeat trump at all costs so we can
have someone quote more normal as our
nominee
they should really coalesce around
someone early i don't know that the
dynamics of the republican party allow
that i don't know that the republican
party
is willing or interested in sort of
anointing someone to replace trump and
so what you could end up with if
desantis runs
if whoever if any of these people run is
okay
nikki haley runs and holds three percent
for a while
and ultimately drops out
that's probably worse for desantis and
better for trump two of that might go to
trump and one of her three points goes
to desantis trump consolidates support a
little bit
uh then ted cruz polls four percent for
a while it ultimately becomes clear ted
cruz isn't going to to be the nominee
again
trump wins by attrition in a similar way
to what happened in the 2016 primary and
there's sort of a couple different
layers of this one is when you zoom out
donald trump
uh incited an insurrection to try to
overturn the actual winner of the 2020
election he attempted to defraud the
electoral vote count with all of these
different techniques asking for 11 000
votes in georgia fake electors all this
different stuff
and he still would apparently easily win
a primary if it were held today that
says as much or more
about the republican primary voter than
it does about trump we know plenty about
trump but it says a lot about the
primary voter that after all that they'd
still be willing to vote for him a
plurality would over any other candidate
but the other aspect of this is
how
committed is the republican party to
actually removing trump because listen
if at this point
51 of their voters are already
interested in someone other than trump
not the same someone but someone other
than trump
the best thing that they could do
is try to consolidate support around
someone early if they decided
based on the polling that desantis is
their best shot
they should be working towards
steering away other people from running
and trying to build up ron desantis at
least for now publicly they're not doing
that although tomorrow on the show i am
going to tell you about the fundraising
um
moves of ron desantis apparently trying
to court some of the large republican
mega donors my guess would be if the
large mega donors say to desantis we
will support you we would rather you
than trump it seems that that could get
his campaign off to a fast start if on
the other hand they say
if it's trump we've got to support trump
because that's still where most of our
voters are
or a plurality of our voters
that may dissuade desantis from even
running but this is very precarious for
the republican party because so many
republicans now particularly because
there was no real primary in the
republican side in 2020 who have been
saying i might want to run it would be
interesting to run i would like to run
this is the open primary and it's hard
to dissuade people from running in an
open primary where there is no incumbent
at the same time
it's bad for them and it's good for
trump so i don't know ultimately what
they will do or how they will manage it
but we will of course be watching it and
right now desantis is the only guy who
maybe has a shot we'll have more on this
on the david pakman show instagram which
you can find at david pakman show also
oh by the way
if you want to hear
a voicemail so vile and so unhinged that
i can't even play it on the podcast
check out my personal instagram david
pakman i uploaded it this morning and it
is uh
it's cuckoo for coco puffs let's put it
that way
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show radical and repugnant congresswoman
lauren bobert is now openly trying to
destroy the constitution the very
constitution that she claims to love
that she claims to treat almost as if it
were a sacred text or a religious
doctrine of sorts she now wants pastors
to preach
how churches can influence the direction
of government now understand that
in order to be non-profit entities and
not pay all sorts of different taxes
churches actually have to avoid politics
altogether and what lauren bobert is
suggesting is not just that churches
get involved in politics but that
churches actually get directly involved
in trying to influence government rather
than just their parishioners or the
people uh attending their church
services and this is the second time in
three weeks that lauren bobert is openly
hostile to separation of church and
state enshrined by the constitution and
bill of rights and they will often not
even justify it in any real way
occasionally they will say you know the
founding fathers were christian so
therefore we don't need separation of
church and state well they may have been
some of them anyway uh but they
recognized the importance of that being
their personal set of beliefs and not
part of
civil government so let's get into the
first clip here
lauren beauberg says we we need churches
influencing government
sorry lauren that's not what the
constitution says
and i believe that great patriots all
throughout this nation
and christians will begin to position
themselves
in these days
and these times the pastors would have a
boldness to speak from the pulpit of
their churches to direct and inform the
church on how to influence the direction
of government
[Applause]
that is the opposite of what the
constitution says needs to be the way
the country is organized and in fact
we already have i mean this the sad
reality is
much like the checks and balances that
trump ignored and seems to have
successfully ignored at least for now in
terms of consequences
in theory
when churches do politics they lose
their tax-exempt status
in practice
i've been covering for close to two
decades churches that do politics
and we almost never see them lose their
tax-exempt status so both what lauren
bobert is saying is both
completely against
both the constitution and the tax code
and they'll probably get away with it
because there is very limited
willingness or resources among the irs
to actually police this now this is not
a new thing with lauren bober
this is lauren bobert's new calling she
recently
again in the trend of trashing the very
constitution that she claims to revere
she said she's tired of separation of
church and state she called it junk in
fact the reason we had so many over
reaching regulations in our nation is
because the church complied
the church is supposed to direct the
government the government is not
supposed to direct the church that is
not how our founding fathers intended it
and i'm tired of this separation of
church and state junk that's not in the
constitution it was in a stinking letter
and it means nothing like what they say
it does
so that is open hostility open hostility
to what is actually in the constitution
now of course the establishment clause
is
where we see that enshrined congress
shall make no law respecting an
establishment of religion that also
means putting the non-religious at any
kind of disadvantage it's one way or the
other
and um the
founding fathers
seemed better
not that they were perfect at separating
their personal beliefs from what should
be
the role of religion in government
um when they talk about you know they
they it is true when they when she
refers to a letter she's talking about
thomas jefferson thomas jefferson
is maybe responsible for the most famous
use of the metaphor separation of church
and state from a letter where he talks
about a wall of separation
and
the new thing that republicans love to
do is to say
it's not really in the constitution it
was just in a letter that jefferson
wrote but
first of all
the letters are relevant in telling us
the intent of the founding fathers you
know james madison
also in in
private what we would call private
communications made clear that any
uh government involvement in religion or
support for any particular religion or
even the placing in a preferred status
of religion over non-religion would be
improper and inappropriate for
government
and also you have the establishment
clause so
as often is the case oh democrats are
going to
try to steal the election and use fraud
and all this but actually they did it
they are that they're actually the ones
that that did that thing
uh whenever they point to something we
should be wondering are they actually
the ones doing it and when they say the
left is destroying the constitution and
wants to use it as toilet paper or
whatever the case may be
we should be wondering whether whether
it is actually they
who are trying to do that and that is
exactly what lauren bobert is trying to
do now to their credit there are some
more mainstream republicans
mitt romney for example
who
doesn't agree with this perspective he
is
as as far as i've most recently seen
from mitt romney
he is personally very religious he's
mormon and on and on but he would take
issue with what lauren bobert says in
this clip
many other republicans won't support it
publicly but they like what she's saying
so they'll just shut their mouths and
then you have the ones that are just
full floated full-throated endorsers
of what lauren bobert is saying and it's
dangerous
and uh if they
end up getting more power
whether it's the house senate more
governorships at the state level they
will try to make this establishment of
christianity in government even more of
a reality than it already is because to
some degree it already is there
which religion gets federal holidays
just christianity right i mean eastern
christmas
there's no other religion that gets
federal holidays um
and so many other things that we've
talked about ten commandments displays
at courthouses and on and on and on it
will get worse okay next lauren bobert
story lauren bobert has been reported to
the fbi
uh for allegedly inciting violence by
saying that we need to terminate the
presidency
of joe biden now she doesn't say
impeachment she doesn't say 25th
amendment she says terminate the
presidency of joe biden and now
she has been reported to the fbi
newsweek lauren bobert reported to fbi
after terminate this presidency tweet
lauren bobert has been reported by
several users the house republican from
colorado on sunday appeared to mock
president joe biden after he mistakenly
said presidency instead of pregnancy
when discussing abortion rights being
restricted in the u.s following the
revoking of roe v wade
um
in response to her tweet actually let's
look at the tweet first quote we need to
terminate this presidency
and quote
repeat the line
unfortunately
you can't just terminate things you
don't want lauren we've got to see this
out through its full term and this is
really getting into fascistic rhetoric
particularly
in light of a former world leader just
being assassinated it doesn't feel like
an overreaction to say that lauren
beaubert should be investigated over
this and the term is stochastic
terrorism i've told you guys about this
before stochastic terrorism is when you
have a large enough audience that if you
feed an idea
to enough people it starts to become
statistically likely that someone will
act on it so for example when you are i
don't know tucker carlson
and if you were if he were and he's not
doing this exactly but if he were to
every night say we need someone to deal
with joe biden in a permanent way
okay he's not saying go out and kill joe
biden but with a large enough audience
it would start to become predictable
that someone's going to try to act on
what tucker carlson is saying in exactly
the violent way that he is implying it
this is not hypothetical
we have seen these incidents happen in
the past there was there's this guy
glenn beck i believe he still is on
the blaze maybe is i think glenn beck is
associated with the blaze a right-wing
outlet
where when he had a program on again i'm
thinking back i think it was on fox
although was it cnn now i don't even
remember he became obsessed with
hammering on the tides foundation the
tides foundation it's an enemy it's evil
it's all this different stuff and
california highway patrol ended up
actually pulling a guy over who was on
his way to do violence to the tides
foundation because he heard glenn beck
talk about it now could you hold glenn
beck legally liable for that no now if
it was significantly more direct then
maybe you could but in that way you're
not going to hold glenn beck legally
liable but stochastic terrorism is a
cultural phenomenon if you
[Music]
continue
hammering on whoever
then these things are going to happen a
more recent example
during the pandemic donald trump talking
about the china virus
china did it never should have happened
there have to be consequences they must
be punished and on and on and on
and it leads to
just on the street hate crimes against
people believed to be of uh asian and
pacific islander origin and we saw it in
the united states random asian women
punched knocked down knocked out in some
cases some of these things caught on
video is trump legally liable no did he
say go out and punch random asian people
on the street no
but from our cultural understanding we
would start to realize oh it's going to
become likely that that will happen when
you have a large enough platform and you
start putting these messages into
people's minds and that's exactly what
lauren bobert is doing here with we must
terminate uh this presidency stochastic
terrorism it's the term we've seen it
before
it's real
and unfortunately
there i mean there's two sides to this
one
a lot of these things
don't rise to the level of criminality
and i'm not saying that they should they
they just often don't and number two
there is so much of this that law
enforcement can't even keep up federal
law enforcement investigative agencies
secret service keeping up threats
it's overwhelming the degree to which
this type of thing is out there and if
you listen again listen to the voicemail
that i posted to my instagram and to my
twitter this morning
you will see that these folks are
everywhere and we've got to be very very
cautious and concerned about them and
lauren bobert is just making the problem
worse
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
the maga love affair with elon musk
seems to be coming to a sort of
predictable end
this all sort of got going around the
twitter purchase that was simply not to
be
uh elon musk um of tesla and spacex fame
announced that he wanted to buy twitter
and that he had reached a deal with
twitter i didn't believe it for a second
i didn't think he was going to buy
twitter then uh sort of like nothing
moved forward for a little bit and uh
elon musk announced that he's having
some concerns about the number of bots
on the platform this was after a whole
flood of right-wing users came back to
twitter following right-wing accounts on
the heels of elon musk's announcement
musk started to say well
i'm not really getting the data i want
about the number of fake users and bots
so i'm putting the purchase on hold and
i said at that point he was never going
to buy twitter and he's not going to buy
twitter and now elon musk actually says
that he's backing out
and it's of course not at all surprising
but in addition to this donald trump and
elon musk are now publicly feuding in
the sense that trump appears to be lying
again and elon musk seems to be telling
the truth now i think a lot of this was
inevitable in the sense that
elon musk is basically a self-centered
opportunist as are many tech ceos i
don't necessarily say that uh
pejoratively although it could certainly
be interpreted as such and um as a
result he and donald trump are now not
getting along well during his rally in
anchorage alaska um donald trump
said the actually you know that's the
wrong order first and foremost um donald
trump at his anchorage rally
said elon musk told me that he voted for
me
but later said i've never voted for a
republican and so therefore he must be a
liar elon musk responded to a report of
that on twitter by saying it's not true
meaning it's not true i ever told trump
i voted for him so trump getting called
out for one apparent lie
then at the anchorage rally trump going
uh on a rampage
attacking elon musk who he also referred
to as leon musk during the rally
another one of our highest priorities
under a republican congress will be to
stop left-wing censorship and to restore
free speech in america
and go out by the way while i'm here and
sign up now for truth social it's hot as
a pistol and you see that i pull that
one right
leon
i tell you what
elon
elon
is not going to buy twitter no where did
you hear that before
from me
from a fake account she says fake a lot
of them
nah he's got himself a mess you know he
said the other day oh i've never voted
for a republican i said i didn't know
that he told me he voted for me
so he's another [ __ ] artist but he's
not going to be buying it
he's not going to be buying it
although he might later huda hell knows
what's going to happen he's got a pretty
rotten contract i looked at his contract
not a good contract right
okay so breitbart highlighting that clip
and then elon musk responded i don't
hate the man but it's time for trump to
hang up his hat and sail into the sunset
democrats should also call off the
attack don't make it so that trump's
only way to survive is to regain the
presidency so the love affair between
the maga people and elon musk
predictably predictably sun setting i
think we could say now let's talk a
little bit about elon musk i get a lot
of people in my audience who are elon
musk fan boys they love him they love
his products they love everything
um and then i hear from people who
absolutely hate elon musk and they see
him as some
right wing extremists and all these
different things
i
it might not surprise you that much the
same way that i don't really care about
or fall into the cult of personality
among politicians i i you know i was a
bernie supporter i wasn't part of the
the bernie cult so to speak there's the
tulsi cult andrew yang had a cult around
him donald trump
i just see these as people
hopefully they do more good than harm
and if i think that they're the best
option i'll vote for them but beyond
that i don't really get too sucked into
the personalities of it and also in
having met a lot of these people
they're just normal people i mean think
about all the flaws everyone you
personally know has they're just normal
people because they're normal people all
of these other people are as well and
much the same way
on a business level if you bet against
elon musk it doesn't seem to be the best
bet
elon musk has had a number of really
successful businesses i've disclosed i
bet on that when in 2015 i bought tesla
stock and the stock went crazy although
now it's down from its peak and whatever
okay okay
it seemed that that was going to be a
business that would grow
and it's by far the largest electric
vehicle manufacturer now in the united
states great the the the degree to which
tesla has advanced
the electric vehicle development and
normalization
uh is incredible and the reason that
every other
vehicle manufacturer now is scrambling
to get more electric vehicles out there
uh is because of the success of tesla
that's a great thing
elon musk also is just wacky on a lot of
political stuff the the the recent
tweets about
uh the the right is where it's always
been but the left has become extreme
that's just wrong that's wacky i don't
know who gave him that idea just wrong
um his recent thing about i'm now going
to vote for republicans i'm only voting
for republicans republicans are better
for this that or the other reason he's
just wrong it's wacky it's completely
wacky disagree with it completely
but at its core
the interpretation that makes the most
sense to me is elon musk has some bad
ideas and some good ideas he uses tax
law to his advantage as all of these
rich guys do he is a self-centered
opportunist who at the end of the day
wants what's best for himself and for
his companies it's not a big surprise we
don't have to deify or demonize and just
recognize it for what it is and all of
that being said
he has never struck me as a particularly
reactionary guy i think he's gotten
sucked into right-wing republican
politics maybe it's hanging around with
rogan i i don't know what it is
but it seemed as though the love affair
between the maga people and elon musk
was destined to end and it seems that it
is indeed now ending so hopefully we can
close the chapter on that i don't
believe he ever intended to buy twitter
and i don't think he's ever going to buy
it hey this is really funny bill
o'reilly's sort of trying to make a
comeback after being completely
disgraced on fox news
last week bill o'reilly played up his
anger where he sort of like is
frustrated with his scripts and looks at
pretending to rip them up and he was
flipping out because of minorities and
gang violence and who the hell knows
what
he now
is offering a service
it's a concierge program
where if you have travel questions for
bill
if you have a problem with a product or
an airline has stiffed you or left you
high and dry at an airport or whatever
you can contact bill
and he will give you advice
and uh this is why i should be doing
this shouldn't i uh anyway tell me if
this sounds appealing to you or if this
is just the latest grift so i get a lot
of questions about people traveling the
world yep
and i because i've been to 84 countries
i can steer you into good places sure
and tell you if you get ripped off
is it really worth paying
12 euro a day
to rent a bike
in copenhagen if you don't know and
you're in copenhagen and you're like is
this a good price
you contact bill o'reilly and he will
tell you get questions about consumer
problems that somebody's contractor is
doing a and then i can steer them
i get financial questions i cannot give
financial or medical advice but i can
tell you what i would do right if you're
like listen bill i know you can't tell
me whether i should open a 529 account
for my kid or whether interest rates are
going i know you can't officially tell
me but what would you do in this exact
same situation
all right so life is complicated
for a concierge membership on bill
o'reilly.com you have me
to answer your questions which we do
within 24 hours right now who is we
is that the royal we i don't know what
that is that's interesting i mean
it's pretty amazing so you might want to
think about it yep definitely something
to think about now you might be shocked
to hear this
it's only
7.92 cents a month for this so
my
belief
is that bill o'reilly isn't
personally answering your questions for
7.92 a month
my guess is that
it's some lackey so you know i'm
considering a new espresso machine
maybe it's time for me to go and ask
bill o'reilly what what about us which
steam wands are the best do i need a
double boiler
uh he's the guy he's the guy that i
guess i should be asking now in all
seriousness i don't know how many people
have checked out bill o'reilly's uh
content recently
it's pretty weird like it it seems
almost like a kind of neutered bill
o'reilly who has to pretend and play up
his anger i'll play a little bit of this
stuff for you
here is
the no spin news from from o'reilly
check this out
uh oh no hold on a second it's actually
hard they make it hard to find previews
let's see if i can even navigate his
website no spin news watch free excerpts
let's see if we can check that out
um
he here's a segment about
hunter biden that he did yesterday this
should be interesting let's check out
his commentary
it doesn't seem
like the hunter biden situation
it's two years
since the grand jury has been impaneled
in
in delaware it doesn't take two years to
do this kind of investigation so
i'm saying that this is just phony
this whole now does he mean that it's
phony to even be investigating him or
that the investigation is a cover full
hunter biden thing how do you see it
yeah the concern i have bill is when you
have already put witnesses in front of
the grand jury
you're supposed to
request that the grand jury once they've
heard from all the witnesses
to vote on whether or not to indict and
and they put witnesses many many months
ago in front of the grand jury
so the question really is do they ever
intend to because i i've never seen it
take this long from the time they had
witnesses in front of the ground i guess
they're saying that the hunter
investigation is a sham that seems to be
the point to win the prosecutor says
okay you have the case now grand jury
now go and vote
on whether or not an indictment should
come yeah the prosecutor is a guy named
david weiss delaware's u.s attorney but
this looks phony to me all right so
there's bill so if you're looking for
hunter biden takes there's an
interesting one
let's see
if i can find oh he oh this has to be
this is going to be good
here bill provides advice if you go to
breakfast at a diner how to save some
money
so
it's really bad in america now it'll get
better but it's going to be a while and
we're going to be absorbing pain
i i can't i'm the idea of bill o'reilly
giving diner advice i am so curious what
he says money is important provides you
with security it provides you with peace
of mind don't waste money right so i'm
going to give you tips
under the smart live banner to save
money
okay we'll do it two times a week we'll
have a lot of tips on the website if you
have tips
please send it to us and share it with
the rest of the world call it bill
o'reilly.com again
okay let us know we'll post them
okay so
uh over the weekend i took the urchins
for breakfast about i don't know a
quarter of a mile from my house
and uh he took it did he say he took the
urchins what is that like his grandkids
uh
they go in and they immediately they
order
two dollar and fifty cents orange juice
uh-oh okay and bill's only worth 85
million so he's not going to stand for
that so little cup
250
tropicana i saw them pour it not fresh
squeeze
okay today i went on the internet
and
56
58 ounces of tropicana
three bucks oh this is i don't this is
the most compelling thing i've ever this
is the most interesting tv bill o'reilly
has ever done
so my urge to spend five bucks
on little cups when you can get 58
ounces and we have in the refrigerator
now does i wonder if phil o'reilly
drinks wine at restaurants because
it's hard to find something more
overpriced than that i mean
this is weird
we have it so look they're like oh what
are you doing
we have oj in a refrigerator what what
what is this five bucks
on fire
then
they order their entrees what they want
it for breakfast and then they order a
side of corned beef hash uh oh
now
the side of corned beef hash in the
place is good
but they didn't want to change the menu
prices so they cut the size in half
it's nine bucks
and why you used to get a pretty good
portion of corn beach half bill is not
getting his corned beef hash and he is
pissed you don't any longer
and they didn't even eat it
this this seems like satire
this this seems like it is a joke we're
full from the pancakes and the omelet
sitting here going
all right let's add it up nine bucks and
five bucks 14 bucks you just set on fire
i think bill's tip is order less food
when you go out eat less food is really
the way to save money
and they did and now the eye roll is the
eye roll
now okay
this is what i'm talking about the urges
have no blanket clue they work they have
to in my house
but dad pays the breakfast oh i guess
he's talking about his kids not even his
grandkids
but
it's that kind of waste you've got to be
thinking about
value
you got to be thinking about this now
there's two layers of this first
hearing bill o'reilly
be pissed off about the size of a corn
beef
beef
corn corn beef
side
is endlessly fascinating i actually
might pay for that i'm now thinking i
might buy this subscription
and send questions about pizza toppings
and how to save money and you know have
them calculate the area of a circle to
tell us that the larger pizza is usually
the better deal that's fascinating but
this is kind of like the latte
millionaire stuff this is a big thing in
the personal finance space which is like
hey listen you know if you just didn't
get your your latte
uh every day you'd be a millionaire you
know in like 17 years you'll you'll be a
millionaire or whatever
you know the reality is that the things
that for most people are keeping them
from being financially independent or
even stable right they're just just even
stable
um
are the cost of housing cost of
transportation stagnant wages it's it's
not real like it's fine this stuff is
fine but it's along the same lines of
get rich by skipping coffee and it's not
really representative of the financial
pressure
that that is on most people but there it
is bill o'reilly fascinating fascinating
stuff there we have a voicemail number
that number is 2192 david p here's a
question about 2024
hey david my name is steve i'm calling
from san diego california please i just
wanted to drop my two cents on
who's better
desantis or trump right who's worse i
guess
i think it's trump i think desantis
obviously
like you say he he probably could do
more damage policy wise just because
he's not
so
crazy yes
but but
he
i think trump would do more damage to
our institution
long term and short short-term just
destroying democracy i just can't
understand
or i can't fathom
seeing trump in office without the
possibility of him looking forward to
having an answer to the voters again
yeah i i understand the point that the
caller is making
but i actually still think that by
virtue of being less cartoonishly unable
to get anything done in the net
desantis would be worse than trump i i
still i still think that but i'm open to
having my mind changed we've got a great
bonus show for you today
uh sign up at joinpakman.com we'll talk
about the twitter elon musk deal
evaporating we'll talk about california
starting to make its own insulin and we
will talk about the euro dollar parody
that has been reached for the first time
in 20 years and i have no plans to take
advantage of it that's for sure a sign
up at jointpakman.com we'll see you on
the bonus show